[Music]
i gotta pull up that wiki
i i i gotta remember that my vision is
more than their vision that's the thing
we could do double kill no too many of
them
what you doing zombie are you out here
putting in work
i feel like holly's already being weird
about me and i don't know why hang on
um you could pretend that they would do
that [ __ ]
but i feel like her behavior is strange
[ __ ] i don't know what to do
she is on me she is on my dick
i could totally have been caught just
there like holy [ __ ] that was bad
do we just pop out here just take the
wrist go done okay bye
i killed the person who i felt was
suspicious of me
and then i did a bunch of sauce [ __ ]
so that's all i'm saying i could kill
andrea
oh [ __ ] that was bad i shouldn't have
done that
oh he's dead that was 100 that was 100
andrea that was 100 andrea literally in
the room that i was in
that was 100 [ __ ] andrea i'm talking
100 why did you run away and not
report the body i i honestly just
panicked that was 100
andrea was in the room that i was in and
i was like [ __ ] i should have reported
it
i wasn't even over there i don't even
know where the body is oh that's
convenient andrea because you just
murdered someone oh my god alana is
totally
totally defecting right now no way you
guys i was on my way i just went through
decontamination there's no way that
that body is my is my work i don't
literally saw you coming from there
where is the body
oh that's convenient that's convenient
andrea it's like where the little med
bay thing is i had just done the [ __ ]
how did
you do the telescope thing
nope nope you're not getting away with
this i [ __ ] up by not reporting it and
i recognized that but i panicked it was
100
[ __ ] this up you guys [ __ ] this up
good luck to you
wait i promise i promise that was [ __ ]
up that was [ __ ] up
that was so brutal what the heck it was
[ __ ] up
right i saw it i saw a [ __ ] body
fault i didn't i didn't i hated myself i
hate myself a lot
that's the worst thing that i've ever
done i've never actually played it that
way before if i'm being completely
honest
i've never i've never done that she was
in the room
and i just went for it
i'm really sorry andrea if you happen to
be watching this
that was not a thing that i'm at all
proud of
you know uh
[Laughter]
i've never done that before that was so
awful
oh i love so much
jesus christ but as soon as i saw
steimer i was like [ __ ] it let's
oh oh oh oh oh oh waiting first timer to
be
okay okay i saw miranda's dead body
outside
the shut door that is the one that is
the room where you walk into and then
you go down and up to electrical
i can vouch for mod mod and i are in the
same area doing tasks
vouch for steiner style text me
diver has been consistently doing tasks
trisha was then with me alana you've
called two out of two bodies
too big no i didn't call the other
bodies diamond did i didn't call that
this miranda is i can literally tell you
all i saw was i walked up on a blue dead
body she is right outside a locked door
i don't know who locked it
but right outside a locked door which
would lead to i don't know the the
hallway that then leads to electrical
i don't i don't know i didn't see anyone
all i saw is miranda's
i saw her walking away from a body
all i saw is miranda's corpse that's all
i saw that's uh that's it
i did not kill miranda i want a hundred
percent one
no one's ejected it was a tie i guess i
just don't uh report anyone else ever
good luck everyone didn't do it because
it was zombae who is
uh my colleague and friend let's just go
this could work you know this this
chaotic energy i've got with this round
could absolutely work
well if we stick together right you want
to just [ __ ]
throw it out because they're not
suspicious of her but they are
suspicious of me
like i could just kill whoever and it
wouldn't matter
that's my logic and then we just [ __ ]
get rid of more bodies
andrea i'm so sorry that isn't everybody
else
it is the dirtiest thing i've ever done
in this game i thought you were my
friends taking this back in taking this
back in all right
it's james not elise it's james not at
least
i need more pets oh
no oh no oh but
yeah ain't got the experience oh heck
we could stick together that could be my
way of assisting
but i don't think
that is going to play like that i really
i really just hate it a lot you know
uh
yes i just went from the right to the
middle to go back up and do that
whatever common task i'm gonna skip for
now can i use this opportunity real fast
by the way so the tasks that we have to
do on the left-hand side right and then
if i look at the map i can figure out
which ones
[Music]
and then if you click the map away it'll
be easier for you to click the
okay what do you we could hang out
and just find someone and then
clear them you know you want to just
let's go here coley
ruffle coley let's go this way we'll
open this
buddy okay bye that's fine you go do
your own thing but it's cool i'll make
it happen
out here by myself
we just need to get away from there okay
okay okay
done
oh wow crap okay so
i found swiss's body in the bottom right
uh in the specimen in the lab the only
person i walked uh i
crossed paths with walking away from the
body if they
didn't vent was alana alana was walking
away from
the area that the body was i don't even
know where it was bruce we passed each
other in that middle room
we did it was the bottom right specimen
is where it's at um
so yeah i didn't even go down there at
any point i just
no i've been alone with i've been alone
with bruce and alana
well just do your tasks and put down a
smile
okay
uh if rockwell could help i just called
him rocco
that would be very handy ugh
coley you got you got so much you can do
here
bud oh my gosh
i need help man
everyone's alive man okay i'm going to
be the one who fixes lights then
that's what we've decided but at least
we split them up
wait did he report it he reported a fly
we have a body we have a body
next to the the satellite thing at the
bottom
um this just i i this just happened
so i just checked the vitals two seconds
ago nobody was dead
so they just died wait where did it
happen rahul uh
bottom like like in them i feel like it
was in the middle so i can clear
that bruce and keem right now were
top left oh man i think this is a
self-report just if the body was not
dead on vitals
see this is the thing now now chilled
cass is switching up
he he was smug before now he's like oh
i'm kind of nervous right now so i don't
know i feel like i feel like it's an act
man
i also think keem is the other killer
because keem gave raul and alibi the
first round
saying they were both on left side they
crossed he was in the clear i think it's
kiman raoul
that's all i'll say feel free to eat
voting
huge donations we got we have melissa
toad for 200
spectre 430 for five hundred dollars and
chug is awesome for
nine hours you're coming through again
yeah yeah thank you thank you so much
thank you all right good on
rahul for for doing a murder hey bruce
what's with the meeting bro uh the
meeting is because
if there are two impostors left
and i don't call a meeting then they all
they need is one more kill in the game's
over
chugs and chugs i want to hear from you
yeah i am completely done with my tasks
that was the first round where i had no
tasks to do i don't know what about you
so i have one more which is the thing
that's at the tree which i was going to
do last time and got
interrupted but that is my last task i
have not done a task yet
all right there we go there's the
imposter right there roll
i love i mean yeah if you want to turn
them that seems like okay buddy if
that's i was just about to say i don't
know why it just turned on me but
i was going to say brah because i was
looking i'm following the damn map
and every time i go to one of these
things it's one room that doesn't have
something i'm supposed to do and i'm
getting
like it's gotta be roll it's gotta be
i mean yeah you guys can do i don't know
what i'm doing you can vote me out if
you want i don't care like
okay
so i need to
put in some [ __ ] work here this loss
all i'm saying is not gonna be my fault
that is all i am saying
kill you
that's that was a bad idea that was oh
[ __ ] no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no lights
quick quick quick quick get him to come
here
okay um
my my justification for this is gonna be
i have no tasks left so i'm sticking
with bruce or i just kill bruce what's
how far away is this [ __ ] kill
you know he is running away from me
but this will clear the body i think
okay okay okay okay
playing with just one imposter is is
rough
huh i think that's the right call
and then and then i think
i can do this
i have to do this right
oh thank god okay
but this is insane wait a minute what's
going on here
so it's me bruce and alana that's it
uh-huh
a lot of chased me around the building
whoa whoa bruce
i've been saying this out loud that what
i was doing was all my tasks were
cleared
so i was 100 just following you because
i had said i had one left i was just
chasing you around
wha i was literally just following you
because my toss is done uh
kim who do you want where are you the
whole round that's what i mean
see this is the thing when i list when i
hear bruce's voice
like this throughout the entire time
playing it hasn't changed
and so i believe him oh it's not bruce
i'm just
based on the tone of his voice alana i
am so sorry
i'm gonna what i'm doing here is asking
where you have been sir it is not bruce
where have you it's not bruce no it's
not bro
there's only three of us left yes yeah
you are crazy i know it's not i know
it's not me
right alana who you voting for well
bruce i'm not voting you
obviously i know because you and i have
just been together
the moment we got separated was oh my
godness the body was in o2
bottom right or bottom left and keem was
walking that way
i feel like i was with you this whole
time bruce i mean that's why i
also felt like you were chasing me yeah
but that's just because you were running
away if you stood there i would have
just stood there with you
boy strat would stick together because i
know that you want you want the motor
this is my worst nightmare bruce this is
my worst nightmare
at least tell us what you were doing
this round i thought i was turning that
thing with the water sure you weren't
sure you were
oh boy alana's gonna win this watch i
really don't
i sure [ __ ] did clean
that [ __ ] up
oh my god i didn't know he was going to
snap you bruce
[Music]
i'm going to side with uh bruce on this
one i was like she's got it
yeah that was like watching a dance
quarantine area and nobody ever
questioned it again
a lot of people had a lot of
astrophysics my apology from 20 minutes
ago about chilled your
rahul didn't do me any favors to be
clear i killed all but
one what a master
i have i have never been played like
that and among uh when you said
that you had to go to the tree to do one
more task my brain went
well it's not her i'm gonna go in that
room and then i killed you in there
she doesn't get killed and then you
killed me
in there